- [Mark] What is your view on sex?
What do you think makes sex
such a fascinating topic?
So many people seem focused on it.
- It feels so good.
- [Mark] All right, Philip.
- Hello, yes.
- [Mark] Philip, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm originally from Detroit.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- Yeah, lived with my
parents and my grandparents,
my mom's parents and my two
brothers, all in the same house.
All seven of us.
- [Mark] And how would you
describe your childhood?
- It was all right, middle
class, middle lower class.
Things were tough in the auto industry
where my father worked.
Which is why we lived at
my grandparent's house.
But there was love and there was...
It allowed me the opportunity to explore.
Being from Detroit,
that's the biggest blackest
city always back at the time.
So being around people
that were not my familiar,
allowed me to learn to grow and appreciate
things that are not me,
but somebody who's not afraid
of trying something new
and that led to itself
in many different ways.
- [Mark] What kind of
stuff did you get into?
- I was always adventurous
so I would always like
take little trips, solo.
Like I've been, one time played hooky
from sixth grade, eighth grade,
and went to go see opening
day of the Detroit Tigers.
So I took the bus down there
and wrote the radio station
that was giving away free tickets.
We were the first 101 people
in line or something like that.
And so I wrote RIP Rocks and I had that
and I had a beer with this young couple
that was the first couple in line.
I was number three in
line to get the tickets.
And, yeah, and then that was
the first time I got drunk
without being around my family.
(laughing)
So that was eighth grade, yeah.
That was fun.
But that led to itself
in many different ways.
The adventurous side that is.
Especially when it came time to,
maturity, puberty and I
was stupid me did not know,
was I gay was I straight whatever.
And so, I told myself, self,
before you start high school,
you better figure it out,
cause I didn't wanna have
any embarrassing issues
happen during school.
I was just paranoid.
So what do I do?
As a 14 year old,
I responded to personal ads
that were in the newspaper.
And I hit up like one of,
I think, like every race,
'cause then it was like, who
would be interested in me?
And in all my letters to
these guys, I was upfront.
I was honest, I'm like,
hey, I'm 14 years old.
I know that's illegal.
I'm sure you would not be interested,
but I need to find out if I'm gay.
And I ask for you to
please spend a day with me
see what happens and maybe
get it in both walls.
There was one response that I got,
from a 27 year old black men
who turned out only lived
like a couple of miles away
from where I did.
And so he arranged to meet me and we met,
we went back to his house
where he lived with his father,
but we were up in the attic,
so the father couldn't hear us.
And for about a few four
hours, we did a lot of talking
and watching a movie and
getting it taken care of.
And that made me realize, yeah, I'm gay.
Not only am I gay, I like sex.
And I not only like sex, I love in me.
And so, I was not as in
not as frequent having sex,
but maybe once every other
month or something like.
After that incident, summer
of '88 and that I guess...
(laughing)
What really took off was when
I got my first job right.
The week after I turned
16, working at Kmart.
And I mean, this is in the hood.
So I'm working, as you
see I'm the bigger person,
meant bigger behind
and you know who likes the
big butts, I cannot lie.
That's when I realized that
there was an appreciation
for me and was hit on
frequently by black men
which just made me all
the more appreciative
and wanting to reciprocate
that appreciation for them
which I did find hubs.
And, yeah, I was picked up a lot.
- [Mark] And where did that lead you?
Well, from there, this is
at what age, this is 16?
- Yes, 16 with my first job.
There were a couple of
guys that came into this
for the Kmart and I was a park collector.
It was one of my many jobs there.
So I'd be out in the parking
lot, picking up things.
And, yeah, I guess my little dirty mind
was trying to get with people
and I like follow the solo guys,
single guys that are
going out to their car,
like, excuse me, excuse me, sir.
You look familiar, are you in movies?
And they bail, well, maybe not
but I mean like adult movies
with men in them only?
And a couple of them got embarrassed or,
we got offended, a couple were laid off
but then that actually
worked a couple of times,
where one guy that would be Mr. Rodrick,
oh, I'll tell you about
me by his master later.
But Rodrick, he was like, well, I'm not,
but you want to make one with me?
And this is like 1990 at this time.
And there, the technology
was not it was nowadays.
So he had a camera though,
but that was just his little pickup line
but he was following my pickup line
and he was rubbing on me.
He was like, okay, fine.
Why don't you get this
entertainment center that,
I want you have to assemble yourself.
And since you get an employee
discount, you hook it up,
you buy it for yourself,
but then come on over
to my place after work,
and so I did that
and proceeded to get into a two
year master slave connection
with master Rodrick,
where I was introduced
to a whole different spectrum of kink.
So 16, 17, 18 years old
until I went to college,
I was master Rodrick's play
toy, pubescent play toy.
But he had a lot of...
Yeah that was fun with master Rodrick.
He liked let their scene.
So he was very macho in shape.
And I'm not the most macho, but nothing.
I mean, I'm neither, but like a Pisces.
I go with the flow, I guess.
And, but master Rodrick
taught me with that.
I'm willing to do whatever it takes
to satisfying alpha dominant man,
with a big D and do what it takes.
And that's the reason
why I probably my grades,
like was really brilliant
at ninth grade, 10th grade
slowly with no, my grade
point average went down
and then went to college
in the widest part
of unfucking Deanna.
And it just seemed like time
stopped in terms of freakiness.
But that was okay.
'cause I was trying to get
a degree and all that stuff
but that didn't pan out so
well, mostly because of them,
my libido took over so I was
trying to find guys in college
rather than trying to study.
And drop out and loiter
around bum-fuck Deanna
for another year or so.
Moved back to Detroit.
And now at this point,
we're in the '98 '99.
So I'm 23, 24 and there's
no restraining me.
I mean, like I would walk three
miles to the nearest gay bar
'cause I didn't have a car.
There was no transportation
that went that way.
So I would do that and
proceed to get drunk
and get hit on and feel my
own hitting on people, guys.
I mean, I got a job in downtown of Detroit
and that made it even worse
because now I'm in the core center,
public transportation runs 24 hours
if I wanted to go anywhere.
And there was a few bars
I would like to go to
and where my success rate
was much better than average.
And I would do that.
And at that point, that's when I realized
that I was a sex addict,
because I mean as soon
as I would be finished,
in seeing the guy out the door,
immediately, I'm like,
okay who's next to allow,
can I get the next dick in me?
There was all these various
levels of things that I did,
like I said with things to Mr. Rodrick.
There was, he had me entertain
him and a buddy of his
and a couple of times, two buddies of his.
So having to satisfy two big
black dicks at once source
feed big black dick at
once, was pretty fun for,
someone in his late teens, early 20s.
But it seems like that
set off a beast in me,
where I wouldn't even have to go to a bar,
I would be slumming
around downtown Detroit,
looking in the back alleys,
picking up homeless men,
picking up crack heads,
having them pick up me.
There was one guy who was
really interested in me
'cause he really liked big butts.
And his name, hand to God,
I remember him singing the
phrases, Michael Jackson.
And this guy was very slender,
slim, my height like guy
and I fucked 24 on him, that was fun.
Then there was...
Oh gosh, I'm so embarrassed
by all this, but it was fun.
I just, I love sex and sex overpowered me.
I left Detroit and moved to
Phoenix to follow my family
because they've been older in
years and my job went South
and I tried to hand it a relationship,
a nice straight in and then
not straight, but a vanilla,
gay relationship with a wonderful
guy with a beautiful heart
but did not have the libido
that I was trained to serve.
And so while dating him for
over that six year period,
I fooled around a lot and that's
where Mr. Curtis comes in.
The second man that I submitted to.
Master Curtis really liked me as a female
and demanded that I get
as female as possible,
if I was going to have the dick again
'cause he gave it to me
one time and it was amazing
and he was not go home
and just, he did it right.
And basically train me to feminize me
or at least bring up
the female side of me,
hand raise where you see the nails
and I can do that as a result.
That's where I do my free time.
Whatever must be done
that pleases the man,
if you're like a lost identity sometimes
because I bite guy see
that, oh, if you can be thin
and you're not muscular
and if you're masculine
sometimes that means
you're not a true fan.
So I mean the ones that
are sticking the modes,
like there're certain type,
I'm canceled out, but that sucks.
But I mean, it's just because
I'm willing to submit obey.
And I like that.
And that's where I'm at right now.
I mean all my personal ads that
I have on various chat sites
and social different places,
it's like, yeah, I'm a freak
and I'd get to know me.
And I've got some guys that...
There's one guy especially right now,
he lives in New York city.
And he was considering moving up this way.
As of our last talk, he's saying,
hey, buddy, you move here to New York?
And it's everything I wanted,
which is a TPE contract.
If TPE is an acronym in the BDSM world
for total power exchange,
where I basically submitted
everything to the man.
And as long as he looks out for me
and takes care of my needs and
whatnot, then he can own me.
I liked that.
And this guy, Mr. Ranch
in a New York city,
it's really weird 'cause
as we've been chatting
the last two weeks only
we've been on communicating.
It's amazing that our
freak levels are the same,
everything is, we're
like two peas in a pod.
The only difference is that
he's a black guy who's the top,
and I'm a white guy who's bottom.
And, but everything else seems
like it's in a perfect sync.
So I can't wait to meet him.
I'd love for him to come here,
'cause I don't like cold weather.
(laughing)
I've got tired of it, but I'm
happy for whatever happens
as long as that's the right one.
We'll find out, I guess.
- [Mark] Are you ever
worried about diseases?
- Oh yeah, definitely.
'Cause I would refuse to
have sex without a condom
for many, many years,
but now I'm with prep,
the whole idea of taking a pill
and not contracting anything
is a wonderful thing.
And that's where the love
of the baby better came in,
once that realized that
product is available, oh yeah.
- [Mark] What product is this?
- Oh prep, a pill that you can take
that prevents transmission of HIV.
- [Mark] Is that right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I'm naive here.
- Okay, yeah.
- [Mark] So your attraction to sex
has it made your quality
of your life better
or has it been a problem?
- Oh, both, I mean, it has been better
in the fact that when you
work in a kinky SM lifestyle,
you can let go some of your hangups,
because you do a lot of embarrassing shit.
Not shit per se.
I mean, there was one guy that
did, but there was another,
that's a different story
that I don't like getting into.
And shit play is not necessarily my thing.
But, having that experience at least,
taught me that it wasn't
the end of the world
and we will deal with things.
So I mean, having sex has
been insightful in areas
that don't relate to sex.
- [Mark] In what way?
- In more like dedication,
commitment to the purpose
that you have a goal.
If my goal is to get a sexy hung man
to make me his little like slip toy
that would make me happy.
But then having that type of drive for it,
helped me with my job that I had,
where I was working telephones
for a telephone customer
service for a decade,
because that was the piss horrible job.
But it got me through
how to get to be on goal.
And now I'm not to give up on it.
The negative things were one time
while at the gay bar in downtown Detroit.
I'm hitting on different
guys and I'm having a success
with like three different guys
that all want to either
take me home with them
or come to my place.
And it's now closing time
and I got the three guys like,
"Oh, are you ready to go?
You ready to go?"
And these two guys don't know each other
and they're not even aware of the fact
that I'm talking to the two others.
And what was embarrassing to say,
need to tell all three, hey,
but then for a minute there
they were all interested in
coming by at the same time
and having a group thing with me.
Man, I'm good with groups
like that, gang bangs.
But because the tension of
them not knowing each other
just made me all crazy.
And yeah, that was a failure night
because I didn't get any
of the three too bad.
But I mean, my God, do I say it?
I've had about 900, over 900 men sex wise
and over 800 were black.
And, it's not my fault though.
Like when I moved to Long Beach,
when I first moved here
in late 2012, early 2013,
I don't know, first of
all, I moved to Long Beach
because of a guy I met online
and we were feeling each other,
'cause certainly he is exactly my type,
I was exactly his type.
And so we were going to set it up
as a side piece arrangement
because this guy had a boyfriend,
same name as me, except
maybe 40 years older,
but we had a lot of similarities,
but he lived out in the
Valley, way in the Valley,
far away and would only see this guy Fred
once every month or something like that.
So it was a very loving
but distant relationship
and Fred being a dick bravo
and mean sex on the regular.
So when I moved here,
things were working out well
in that aspect, he had a bad leg,
so he could not move right.
So he could just bend down basically,
and I would give him oral.
For 40 plus days, I was he's
every night oral flit toy.
And I had a lot of fun with that
and there was a nice commitment there,
but then, Phil and Fred get in an argument
or something like that.
Fred decides to break
up with Phil supposedly,
and wants to pursue
something with me he says.
I'm not comfortable with that
because I don't wanna be
seen as a home wrecker,
'cause there was a love
there between Phil and Fred.
And so I tell Fred, hey, hey, slow down,
I'm sure the two of you will work it out.
And they did, if they were doing this
Fred decides in his head
that it was my fault
that I was trying to break them up.
Even though I'm submissive a bit,
I do not pry on people's toes.
I've always been just the demure
through as I'm instructed.
And so Fred, we were roommates,
because Fred is homeless
and I did not want Fred to be homeless,
so I was like, hey, let's
get an apartment together.
And we did, and things were
nice for that first month,
but then, after this whole
issue with his boyfriend
they get back together and Fred
decides that it's my fault,
I'm a home wrecker, I'm a bad evil person.
And he proceeded to abuse me physically,
mentally financially and a
couple of times sexually.
Where like, out of rage
I don't know where,
as I'm laying down on my stomach on bed,
'cause after a fight I just ran away
and went to the bedroom.
He follows me in there and just
comes up and bam, fists me,
and I mean like most of
his forearms up in there,
and yeah, I felt violated,
for a minute or two,
'cause that was just a shock,
and that was just part of that
license man, such a psycho.
Followed by arousal, the whole domination,
the whole violent, rough, aggressive sex,
that I had in various forms prior to then,
just to kind of whole new level.
But, Fred and I didn't fuck around
because after that abuse,
he treated me like,
I guess like how
Cinderella was treated by,
her fucking sisters and
like where they were just
damning her every single day.
There was no appreciation of
her, none with me by Fred.
I would have to bring home other guys,
and would while Fred played
out in the other room,
and there was a okay arrangement,
'cause I mean, I was able
to have guys over and...
This is where I was trying
to get to earlier, sorry.
One of my fuck buddies, within
the first week of hooking up,
he's like already over
three times that first week.
And he's like, hey, can I
bring a guy over next time,
to share with me, you?
Like, okay, I've done two
on one before, I don't mind.
I'm a great person to just spit roast.
You know what to spit roast is?
- [Mark] I don't.
- Okay, to spit roast is in circles.
Imagine like a barbecue, where
the pig is on this open spit,
rotating in shape, but
get rid of the flame
and get rid of anything rotating
and insert me for the pig
and insert instead of
the two big metal rod
that goes through, just one
big dick shoved up my butt,
another big dip down my throat,
and I will be servicing both dicks
at the same time with
their own dedicated hole.
I don't know how freaky you
want it to get, but I mean,
I've got amazing snap back for a booty
that has taken massive sizes.
Like, oh my God, that's
some good stuff, sorry.
But yeah, and then, when I stepped back,
I'm good at the damn spit roast.
And I would just love to please the guys
that Dante would bring over
because that was the role
of being the submissive obedient play toy
of dumb man, supposedly.
I'm not gonna tell you
that one type of story,
'cause that's damaging bad,
but it would be that
Dante would bring over
a different guy, every
single time he came by,
for a three month period.
Three or four nights a week.
So when you add that up,
I mean that's like 40 guys
that are new dicks in me.
And as a result, oh yeah,
that's why I never had double penetration.
I'm not gonna get fucking
double fucking in the ass,
by two different dicks.
I can do one in each ramp on of hole,
I can do double oral
because as you might see,
I got no teeth long story on
those, but that's irrelevant.
But yeah, my oral game
went from a 10 out of 10
when I had teeth so I was told.
To just, I mean, amazing insanely good.
But I mean, when you have 100s of dick,
you learn tricks and techniques
on things you pick up.
And that's the nice thing is that
whenever I have sex nowadays,
that first time with
someone be are blown away.
I like that feeling.
That's mine, one that has been groomed,
trained, owned by black
men, and I don't mind.
Hence the reason why a
predominant number of hookups
have been with men of color.
I like the freak in me
and I like the fact that I
don't deny the freak in me.
Yeah, if we can, I just try and find a way
now to incorporate all my fun,
like the guy in New York city,
like he's interested in
making videos with me,
adult ones, let me post online
which I already have a
couple of those right now.
Those are just me writing my
oral worship as I call it.
Going down on my fuck bud with
10 inches all the way down.
And then another guy that had the same
but it seems like always
when I try to get the filming
of more kinky stuff, things fall apart.
I was hoping secretly that
you could help with that.
But don't, yeah, 'cause I mean,
like if I can do Jordan Knight again,
for the call Jordan Knight
is my street brother.
Basically cork prank me one night,
when I got a motel room,
'cause I was homeless.
I've been homeless for the last
five years until last year.
And then I got an
apartment down the street.
But during that homeless period,
yeah, I developed a street family
and my street brother
came to my motel room
and basically cork prank me from,
me having you guys come over and whatnot.
It's like, he says to me, I'll
make it up for you tomorrow,
I'll find a guy for you wuwuwu.
And that following night
I had a motel room,
I mean for that second
night a different motel.
And he brought a friend
of his over Mr. Tyrique.
And Tyrique was very fun,
very metal hung, 11 inches.
And my brother would watch my brother
as I call him what he's watching,
and he's like asking Tyrique, how is it?
How is my skills?
And not to toot my own horn,
but I mean, oh damn good.
And I mean, I already know this
because when I can hear the guy's reaction
and feel the region, his appreciation
and the hookups becomes
sleep and fuck buddies,
you don't know you're good.
So I mean, Tyrique says,
yeah, this is damn good.
My brother, who I was given rumors of him
being my go home also
leaves my line of sight,
as I'm, on mine, on all fours on the bed,
I'm working on Tyrique.
My butts up in the air and I feel a slap.
And then I could tell
that my brother was funky,
positioning himself on the bed behind me.
Oh my God, my brothers is gonna
fuck me, my black brother.
And yeah, that missile went through
slowly all the way through
and then pump pump pump,
and he went like a jackhammer
and for a good two minutes
and that's the way he
likes his stripped him.
But I mean, I had my butt beat up by him
as I was giving head
to Tyriques 11 inches,
with my brother oh is 12, makes 23 inches,
total number of dick in me.
Hence with my call that
night Jordan Knight.
'Cause that was most memorable.
And when most memorable type
events like that happened,
I try to recreate it as
frequently as possible.
Not necessarily with the same guys
'cause I would not want to
touch my brother like that.
And, but just have high quality free time
and have it recorded and posted online
and try and get some money off it.
That's fine with me because hey,
I'm on social security disability.
I don't have any income.
I mean, besides my monthly check-in
when it's half of the amount of money
that you were making 10 years ago
you know that next to nothing,
you've got to come up with
a way to do something.
And my mind there's too many
mental and physical problems
that prevent proper work.
What else is someone's folks to do?
I don't mind being a
frequent at the table.
- [Mark] So where do you
think this behavior came from?
Did you think there's
something in your childhood
or do you think it's just
your DNA is wired this way?
- Well, like I said, I
suspected I was gay things.
I was an odd ball in my family
in the fact that I was super intelligent,
just did, as they said.
And so, I mean, my parents had got me
to tried to do their best
giving me chemistry sets,
at 10 years old or something like that.
And things just, I could not figure out
what would make me happy.
I was depressed inside.
I don't know, it's just
a middle child syndrome
gone haywire or what,
but I was a lost soul
despite having good grades
and having a family that stability,
I just, something didn't feel right,
and the answer was I was gay.
And when you're navigating
this in the late 80s early 90s
where you didn't have ailing,
and there was no youth
pushing of respectability.
I mean, what Richard
Simmons, who wasn't out
that was a flamboyant nightmare.
I'm not that.
So how do I never keep the world seeing
if I grew up in today's environment
I probably would have
been a lot more stable
and not been as adventurous,
in terms of sex, whatnot,
and been a different person.
But I mean, going
through the things I did,
I thought I has given me a lot of strength
that I would have not had otherwise.
So I'm happy about that.
- [Mark] Were you loved
as a child, do you think?
- Yeah, I would say yes.
My selfish side of me was that
the fact that my two brothers,
one older, one younger,
are born on the same day, six years apart.
And it felt like big twin,
little twin growing up,
when I'm the monkey in the middle
and because they had
bigger birthdays than mine
and just it felt like there
was an overlooked thing.
So I was fine with being
the independent side
because I don't have to follow
the rules of the family.
Just figure it out myself
and make myself happy Sex made
me happy, didn't expect that.
- [Mark] Are you happy today?
- Oh yeah, I am.
I'm not with, the exact
position where I'm at
in those slum apartment
that I have currently
but I'm 90% of where I wanna be.
Yeah, when Mr. Ant comes
to town, where I meet him
hopefully its 100% because, oh, wow.
I mean, even though, and
like I said that this guy
and I had been talking and
having such a wonderful thing,
he is essentially like me and, oh my God,
you should see some of
the texts that we have.
I don't have my phone with
me, so you can't see 'em,
but like one of the messages,
like I expect you to
have your hole cleaned,
I tend, I get home, so I
then I'll have something to,
pre-moved for me.
I love raw sex.
I love the feeling of a nud in me.
Where it just fills me, yeah.
Down below or swallowing the seed.
And yeah, I've done threesomes, foursomes,
gang bangs up to eight guys one time,
seven guys twice I think in
the same room at the same time
that was pretty wild
to know that I was able to
sexually satisfy so many at once.
- [Mark] And you're the
only white guy in the group.
- Yes, more of in the middle, I'd say, yes
there was maybe one or two
occasions of various group times,
where there was another white guy there.
And the only way I would be interested
in doing something with him,
is if I was commanded to,
I mean, yeah, commanded to,
that's what master Rodrick did.
Master Rodrick also commanded
me before he went to prison,
which is why...
And then I wound up moving to college
within a month or two after that.
But that I'm to be a sex
toy solely for men of color
and hopefully black
men only, but well not,
it's not possible to find a
black man all the damn time
especially in bum fucking Deanna.
But if at least was an Arab
man or a Latino, Hispanic,
then it's like a partial
credit, but being viewed.
And in Detroit, I lived in a very Arab
filled heavy concentration number,
and Arab men are like
black men in the fact
that they like big butts
and they're very low key.
I was at the casino downtown
Detroit on my lunch break.
And I'm under my own slots.
Oh, 'cause the casino is
right across the street
from my job.
And so I'm like looking
at the different slats
and there was a guy, an Arab man,
sitting alone in one row
of mangroves of the slats.
And he says, I'm Amy,
and as I'm coming closer
you can see this boom,
like super big tank top, through his pants
but not out to be graphic
or anything like that.
And I turned around and motion
with my boot and looked back
and caesium looking and
I told him to follow me.
We go to the bathroom,
one of the bathrooms there
and it being a casino luxury place,
individual stalls were
large and quiet enough
to where no one can realize
that there's two guys in there,
or one sort of anything.
And we fooled around and
was like, yeah, he's not,
like packing any thing for, fake in there,
that was the real deal.
So I tell him hey, after work
I got to come back and go back to my job,
but as soon as I get out, I'm coming back.
And he waited at the same slot machine
and hey, he was great.
- [Mark] You've been in love before?
Have you ever been in love before?
- There was that one guy
I said that I fell for.
That was not my type physically,
'cause he was built like a linebacker,
but he had a cute smile and
he liked the way I looked
and I loved the fact that
he had a sincere heart
and that's why I tried get
into a relationship with him
and had one for six years,
there were ups and downs.
Like I said, because
even though he did not
get in the right spot 'cause I mean
he had an average sized, dick, my ex.
But there was a love there,
but the need for high
quality power fucking,
this overwhelmed me.
So yeah, I cheated, even
though we were a couple
and I knew that since we
weren't living together
when I lived downtown Detroit,
he had a hub city state at
with a couple of friends of his
and I knew that they would
fool around on occasion.
So I just told myself self,
allow yourself to sing.
And that's where then that
super sweat in me came by
where I would have five
different guys in a week,
every week, like, as I'm
picking up, like I said--
- [Mark] How many times
do you have sex in a day?
What's the most you've had in a day?
- Okay, well, I was at a bath house once,
I had the one right down the street
that last time I was there,
I had eight different guys
in an eight hour period.
And I would say closer
to a six hour period,
they were just like rotating
in and out of the glory halls.
Not that it was just oral only,
but that's where I was at with them.
A couple of did come back to my room,
'cause I had a little tiny
room that you could rent out.
Then there was, like I said the gang-bang
that I had with the eight
guys, that was one time.
That was an overnight period.
- [Mark] So orgasm, how many orgasms
would you have in a day?
- Well, you know full well
that the orgasms amount that you had at 18
is different than today.
So mine's been on a declining scale.
Like everyone else, every guy I imagine,
but as a bottom and
concentrating on the top
I don't worry about having,
I mean, jerk-off orgasm,
having the sensation of the dick in me,
excites me when I'm performing oral
and he unload in most cases I can swallow.
I don't have a problem with that,
and then of course, makes him
say that he was satisfied,
so therefore I'm satisfied.
That just goes in with
that submissive, obedient,
just pleasing others
personality that I have.
- [Mark] And are you
using drugs to do this,
or you just naturally,
have a strong libido?
(siren wailing)
- I have, I do whatever
the guy, the man shows.
So he was a drug fiend,
I would be on drugs too.
I would otherwise,
if he didn't do much
like outside of for 20,
then it would be poppers
that I would do separately.
The little vials that
you'd get at the sex shops
or corner stores that when you sniff it...
For me, I don't know what it does,
but it relaxes muscles and a
big way where then I can take
I'm like a size dick, 'cause as I said,
I've got a tight pussy slit for a hole,
despite the fact that he'd
been beat down so many times
it's amazing that my snap back,
goes back to where it looks
like it's a virgin pussy,
as I'm told by many of black men.
I mean, I can't see it
myself, and I don't know.
I don't know what pussy look like,
but some gay say these things.
But after my brother's night
with after Jordan Knight,
that was late night, nitty
afternoon, the following day,
so, I mean, within 16 hours after that,
I was fucked again by
a different black guy.
And he was a modest eight.
So he's clearly like four
inches smaller than my brother.
But while Mr. Pharaoh is fucking me,
he's like, man, this is
why I love fucking you.
You just wrapped around
my Dick, like a glove.
And I'm thinking to myself, wow.
And if he knew that I had a dick,
that is almost twice his size.
And none of them working me
out within the last 24 hours,
he wouldn't believe it,
because Pharaoh was
loving it, I loved it too.
But I mean, I don't think my stent
that comes that fast all the time.
I can't imagine that it
would still be as good now
but I mean, last time I was banged out,
I had to like pull my cheeks apart,
so that way he couldn't
figure out how to get through.
I'm sorry, did I do anything with this?
Okay, good, that if he was enjoying it,
then, yeah, the last time I got
banged up with two weeks ago
by a 20 year old, it was
thanks to Mr. Dante's,
bringing over guys all
the damn time thing.
He picked up the guy on the train
as going from LA back to Long
Beach and brought him over.
And the kid said he was 19.
And like I said, with good guys
that I had a good time with,
well, Dante was being
the drama queen whatever.
I would like hook up with him on the side
the other guy on the side.
So did that with the 18 or
20 year old, 19 year old.
He always kept on changing it,
'cause it was always 20.
And then like after a month
it's like, oh no I'm 19,
after a month, no, I'm 18.
And at that point I froze into myself.
Is he gonna dare say he's 17 or under,
'cause that was amazing what he was doing.
I did not pursue it, but
at this I got paranoid
that he would be reporting
me or something like that.
So I was like, hey, you
know what, one more time,
and then we're gonna have to pause
until I get verification
from how old you are.
- [Mark] And how old are you?
- I'm 46 right now.
Yeah, at that point, that was in 2013.
So I was 38 at the time.
And so like, look, I was 14 when I lost,
when I gave it up and had
it on a regular basis,
before turning 18, how would
I be grudge someone else,
but be honest?
I was honest with my guys
and if he was upfront
if he was underage and said
like, hey, I'm only 17.
I'll be like, okay, guess what?
We're working this out, fine.
I know we could have
been wonderful fuck-ship,
but you gotta be honest
to that for the core
of what makes sex good, honesty.
- [Mark] But what would you say
is the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- Time will sort out any
crises, any problems,
just allow that time to happen.
Don't fuck with time by, in
trying to rush into things,
like the relationship with that guy.
But I had the love
that because we're still
friends to this day, the ex,
the love that I had, but that
was best not the right time
for me to have tried that.
I'm glad I did ultimately
'cause that was a wonderful
friendship that was formed
but take the time to do things right.
Because you may not get a chance again.
And if you really care about
something, give it your all.
- [Mark] What is your view on sex?
What do you think makes sex
such a fascinating topic?
So many people seem focused on it.
- It feels so good,
that you're having that
tab B to slot B type feeling
is one that is not done
to anybody, everybody
unless you're a shit up super mega slit
but just the fact that
it's intimate in a way
it a private personal thing
just between the two of you.
So to speak, where if you're
not doing anything stupid
you could make a very good time out of it.
And that is what feels good.
Something that is not done by many others.
I like that independent thing
that I'm doing things of my
own that make me happy in bed.
Just having my holes
stretched out is very fun
and it relaxes me.
- [Mark] Excellent, well
Philip, thank you so much
for describing your fascinating life.
- Oh thought fascinating, thank you.
- [Mark] Very interesting.
- I blush out sometimes, but yeah,
I didn't know where to go,
'cause that's what sex is.
Sex will involve a lot of
stuff, that's freaky deaky,
and you might have to explain yourself.